so we had some major media news
yesterday many of you emailing me about
it tweeting to me about it sending me
very very respectful uh
all sorts of messages about it um the
story is chris wallace leaving fox news
and joining cnn plus cnn plus being a
new
streaming service from cnn and this is a
really big deal in the political media
space because chris wallace as many of
you know
was one of what we would call the lone
occasional voices of reason on fox news
which was basically a sea of propaganda
and i've had a number of different
thoughts about chris wallace's presence
on fox in the past which there's no
better time to talk about than now but
let's first take a look at chris wallace
making the announcement yesterday on fox
news sunday after 18 years this is my
final fox news sunday it is the last
time and i say this with real sadness we
will meet like this
18 years ago the bosses here at fox
promised me they would never interfere
with a guest i booked or a question i
asked and they kept that promise
i have been free to report to the best
of my ability to cover the stories i
think are important to hold our
country's leaders to account
it's been a great ride we've covered
five presidential elections interviewed
every president since george h.w bush
traveled the world sitting down with
francis emmanuel macron and russia's
vladimir putin
and i've gotten to spend sunday mornings
with you
it may sound corny but i feel we've
built
a community here there's a lot you can
do on sunday mornings the fact you've
chosen to spend this hour with us
is something i cherish
but after 18 years i have decided to
leave fox i want to try something new to
go beyond politics to all the things i'm
interested in i'm ready for a new
adventure and i hope you'll check it out
and so for the last time dear friends
okay so he's leaving he said he has new
projects and then within two hours
cnn announced he's going to be joining
as an anchor of their new streaming
service cnn plus which doesn't exist yet
it's expected to debut
early next year so
is this good or is this bad and for who
or whom depending on your preference um
on the one hand it's been clear for a
long time
that
chris wallace's days at fox
were probably numbered if he was going
to keep asking just real questions of
republicans when republicans would be on
and we had all of these different
examples of i don't even remember what
senator it was who was talking about
debt and chris wallace pointed out well
a lot of that debt accrued under trump
not under joe biden you know this is
looks like in other countries we would
call it basic journalism it was rare on
fox and because chris wallace was doing
it and he was doing it with the
republicans as well as democrats it was
rare it stood out and there was some
sense that at some point he might be
gone
now
on the one hand you could say his mere
presence on fox was a net positive
because
there were some viewers
who were fully accepting all the
propaganda
and even if they didn't care that this
is what chris wallace was doing they
would be exposed to it for a moment and
maybe he would change some minds and get
some of these mindless fox viewers to
think hey here's another perspective
the counterpoint to that is that chris
wallace did provide fox news
cover
in a major way to be able to say
we're fair and balanced we have news and
we have opinion that's one they've been
hiding behind for a very long time it's
like yes you have news and opinion it's
blurred and even the news sounds like
opinion and we have plenty of people
holding republicans accountable like
chris wallace they used to have shep
smith although shepsmith left
and
in that sense
it provided cover for fox news to be
marginally more plausible as an actual
news channel of sorts with actual
journalism being done and so with chris
wallace leaving
does it
prevent fox from now having that cover
my bottom line on this is as follows i
think it's a
you've got two sides of the scale and
they're they're really both doing work
it's close right on the one hand his
presence is good as an alternative to
the propaganda on the other hand his
presence allows fox to run interference
my expectation
is that now chris wallace will be
replaced with a total partisan hack
uh people on on twitter were talking
about dana perino dana parino who's a
fox anchor now
was george w bush's press secretary
right i mean give me a break guys so
he'll probably replace be replaced with
someone much worse i think that by a
small margin
small margin
wallace on fox was a net positive
he did
ask real questions and maybe convince
some people
he did allow fox to say we have a
variety and we have journalism and we
have chris wallace i think the the
benefit of having him there
slightly slightly outweighed the very
pernicious reality that he was running
interference for what was otherwise a
complete and total propaganda uh media
outlet and in particular if he now gets
replaced with tucker or a hannity wanna
be not not literally tucker but a tucker
or hannah b uh tucker or hannity wannabe
um i think we are worse off and so the
criticism that he ran interference for a
horrible propaganda network is 100
accurate
and i would say by like five percent
him being there was a net benefit if you
disagree with me i want to hear from you
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is
curiosity stream and you can get
curiosity stream one of our sponsors for
just 15 bucks a year when you use my
link below this will give you access to
the world's best selection of
documentary films there's always
so many that you can't get on netflix
hulu or amazon i just finished watching
a tremendous film the ceo of sinaloa
sinaloa a region of mexico it's about el
chapo fascinating fascinating curiosity
stream is a must-have
if you love documentaries they always
have the best and newest titles they're
always adding new things to the library
and you can watch on all of your devices
they've got documentaries on every topic
you can imagine curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off a subscription
making it just 15 bucks a month go to
curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below